[Music]
vaccines facilitating safe travel
climate change how did the european
parliament
help shape the beginning of 2021
nearly a year into the covit 19 pandemic
the first vaccine was developed
parliament supported the speedy
authorization of safe jabs
and backed their joint purchase for eu
countries
to improve europeans health and better
face future health crises
meps also endorsed the new 5.1
billion euro eu for health program
with vaccines came the opportunity to
ease travel restrictions between eu
countries
parliament fast tracked the approval of
the eu digital covert certificate
to promote safer and easier travel
crises often feed inequality meps voiced
their concerns about
lgbt iq rights and the erosion of media
freedom in some eu countries
fundamental pillar of the european union
is freedom of expression
and justice and rule of law parliament
backed the so-called rule of law
conditionality
which puts member countries that don't
respect european values like democracy
and human rights at risk of losing funds
meps also took action to combat climate
change
committing to climate neutrality by 2050
backing funds for environmental programs
like life
and biodiversity and circular economy
goals for 2013.
with the united kingdom no longer an eu
member it was time to rethink the eu
uk relationship parliament ratified the
trade and cooperation agreement
the conference on the future of europe
was launched at the european parliament
an opportunity for all europeans to
present their ideas
and decide on what the eu should look
like
the next six months at the european
parliament looks set to be just as
action-packed
with the state of the eu debate
greendale legislation
the soccer of prize and more